brady singer will make his 17th start
6'5 right-hander out of the university
of florida
he has had an up and down sophomore
season arrives great career numbers
against kansas city
the ball to left field hit toward the
gap and it splits the gap and goes to
the wall
another opposite field hit for luis
arrives an
opening double in the first inning
suicide already in scoring position for
josh donaldson two strikes to donaldson
one hit deep to center heading back as
taylor looking up
off the wall arise held up for a while
he's being held at third base and
donaldson sneaks into second
with another double marnick had a tough
ball game yesterday
chance to do some damage here in the
first inning with two men
in scoring position
back to singer he knocks it down and
arise will score with the ball rolling
to the backstop here comes donaldson and
it's two to nothing
and on a comebacker to the mound instead
of an out the royals don't get that the
twins scored two runs
now here is kirilla
chopper right side and that will leak
through for a base hit
larnick around third he'll score a soft
ground ball but it got
past alberto and it's three nothing
twins
well let's take a look at the home
furniture pitching stats from
j hat four and three the overall numbers
don't look impressive but he's coming
off his
solid start against the indians
bouncer left side scooped up by
donaldson
one away then the league and home runs
two years ago with 48
to the mound easy play for half
two down quickly and santana will hit
with the bases empty and it's a guy that
half would like to get for
a number of reasons not the least of
which is salvador perez
is on deck and it looks like he'll lead
off the second inning
seven pitches in a one two three first
inning for j j-hat
one ball two strikes hit sharply
and caught by lopez at the top
of his lead wow i'll tell you what
you want the all-state good hands play
here it comes to you right now great
timing
you see him he timed it perfectly you
could see him he almost like he skipped
with his foot just to wait to jump at
the right time
he is some kind of shortstop in second
baseman here comes salvi just named to
his
seventh all-star game
he bangs that one to right field down
the line into the corner it goes
and gone home run salvador perez
number 20 this year crowd loving this
here
salvador perez went way out that ball
was
way up and away from him and he said i
got enough power to hit that out what a
beautiful swing dozier went two for four
with the double yesterday
he gets a base hit to left field alberto
will be held at third base
now he's coming home as the ball was
bobbled and the royals are within one
and dozier moves into scoring
position michael a taylor's so
quiet so poised he has a perfect
mentality
well struck left center field
that'll get to the fence dozier scores
to tie it
and taylor takes second base great at
bat by michael taylor
two on one out runner's break the throw
by rorfett
got him perfect throw by rory
i'll say donaldson he didn't have to
move his glove is right on the back
this will be pitch number eight
swung on and miss struck him out on the
slider
and brady singer gets out of a mess
in the third inning way to execute
there is hanzer alberto oh
that ball well struck to left field
that's a way back and that ball
is the first home run as a royal for
hunzer
alberto gave him the lead a two run
shot he barreled it look at the swing
great head position
there but he catches that slider out
over the plate and gets them back under
side with some backspin
and it carried it out of here widow for
two in this one twice grounding out
rips it to left
another double for the royals 20th for
win
boyara all over that half breaking ball
when he's up and they are not missing
[Applause]
jorge solaire slaps one off the
shortstops club
merrifield will race to third because he
had to make sure
that polanco would not catch that on the
line
so first and third for kansas city here
in the bottom of the fifth glen now
santana
then he rips one to left merrifield will
score
and the royals go in front six to three
the pitches that j hat has missed on the
royals have not
those those balls out over the middle
that's what hitters look for they look
for the mistake so it's jake brent's
time
too short nicky to second to first
double play they score a run but the
royals get two outs
[Applause]
infield in ground ball second they're
coming home
safe he got his left hand in there in
time
they are gonna check this one ow
yep i thought that would be
the case the royals do not got that
extra seventh run they need to clutch
two out base hit from solaire
ball gets away here comes lopez and the
royals get
that insurance run they were searching
for
one and two the count
he struck him out ball game over
nine game losing streak over the royals
win it
seven to four alberto
with a big home run his first as a royal
broke the tie
salvi the all-star gave him their start
with a home run to right
way to go scotty boy
great finish right there alberto first
home run
i tell you that the offense looked good